[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct je suis ravi de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir on va faire le point
sur cette journée de grève
interprofessionnelle dans le pays à la
paix de la CGT SUD et Force Ouvrière ils
étaient 13000 à Paris selon la police à
battre le pavé un mouvement qui n'est
donc pas massif mais marqué par la
présence dans les cortège de salariés
bien différent dépassant largement le
conflit dans les raffineries la
contagion est-elle en mars comment les
députés peuvent-ils répondre à la grogne
sur les salaires grand débats dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
7 mois et demi 7 mois et demi seulement
au pouvoir et un bilan politique qui
fait pas lire dans Vie beaucoup de ces
successeurs notre grand témoin ce soir
va nous faire découvrir un autre Pierre
Mendès France intime romanesque et d'une
clairvoyance infinie sur lui-même 40 ans
jour pour jour après sa mort le
réalisateur Yves gelan lui consacre un
documentaire Mendès la France nous en
parlerons avec lui enfin nous affranchis
ce la chronique parlementaire d'Elsa
mondingava le 49-3 c'est pour demain et
pour après-demain l'oeil sur l'Europe de
Richard Werly les pistes de l'Union pour
réduire les prix d'énergie et le parti
pris d'eph chef tel de libération la loi
de climat des avouées par les mers voilà
pour le menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
certains rêvaient d'un mouvement de
grève générale dans tout le pays ça n'a
pas été le cas mais tout de même on a
manifesté dans pas moins de 140 villes
dans tout le pays aujourd'hui cheminots
aide-soignant routier lycéens on va
faire le point sur cette journée
interprofessionnelle à l'appel de
plusieurs syndicats bonsoir Louis
Marguerite et bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes député renaissance de
Saône-et-Loire bonsoir Aurélie ravi de
vous retrouver député insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis vous étiez à nouveau
dans le cortège cet après-midi après la
marche de dimanche à l'appel de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon bonsoir Sophie Binet bonsoir
et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
secrétaire général de la CGT cadre la
CGT largement à l'initiative de cette
grève alors déjà mouvement qui n'est pas
reconduit à cette heure on peut le dire
ça dépend en fait c'est les salariés qui
décident sur le terrain en nager et donc
il y a des entreprises dans lesquelles
il y a des reconditions qui sont votées
c'est pas nous qui décidons au plan
national alors on se parle c'est pas
pris alors il y a des âgés c'est c'est
des battu dans des âgés et je pense
qu'ils vont se réunir demain pour faire
le bilan de des âgés et vous avez des
chiffres parce que alors on se parle il
y avait toujours pas des chiffres de la
CGT tout à fait si on les a sortis quand
même depuis 4h30 donc 72
70000 à Paris donc une mobilisation qui
franchit un cap par rapport à au 29
septembre et au plan national on est
au-dessus de 300 000 on n'a pas encore
réussi à tout conglomérer donc le bilan
de la journée c'est que on franchit un
cap il y a tous les secteurs présents et
notamment des taux de grévistes
intéressants dans l'éducation nationale
dans
les transports et donc on voit qu'il y a
une colère qui monte très bien je
voulais simplement avoir les chiffres
mais je vous donnerai la parole sur le
bilan succès ou non de cette de cette
première journée donc 300 000 pour la
CGT 107.000 pour le ministère de
l'Intérieur l'historien Sylvain boulouc
spécialiste des mouvements sociaux va
nous rejoindre quelques instants le
temps pour Stéphane blackovski pour tous
ceux qui ont tout raté la journée et
bien de rembobiner un peu on va refaire
un peu un peu le match à la fois dans la
manif et dans l'hémicycle si j'ai bien
compris d'accord tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes alors
à tous si j'ai bien compris ce soir
alors si j'ai bien compris Myriam après
donc la grande marge de dimanche
aujourd'hui c'était la grande grève donc
a priori le gouvernement est pris pour
cible à chaque fois pour ces deux
mouvements de contestation donc on
s'attend ce qui soit un peu dans les
cordes or surprise ce matin sur RTL
Gérald Darmanin n'était pas loin d'être
sur la même ligne qu'elle est CGT il
réclamait lui aussi des augmentations de
salaire quand il dit que les Français
qui réclament des hommes en son salaire
il les comprend qu'on écoute
il constate que leur salaire n'a pas
suivi l'augmentation des prix il
constate qu'une partie pardon des
patrons se rémunèrent et que cette
rémunération est disproportionnée par
rapport à ce que touche une partie des
salariés la force de travail pour parler
comme Monsieur Martinez et je pense que
quand on est sensible à la guerre de son
peuple comme les présidents de la
République on constate ensemble que oui
une partie des salaires doivent être
augmentée alors pourquoi il y a une
magnifique station puis finalement tout
le monde est d'accord en fait je crois
qu'avait quand même un mouvement apport
castré de la part du majorité et du
gouvernement et on voulait un petit peu
montrer du doigt les grands patrons
puisque car le livre réputé donc proche
d'Emmanuel Macron c'était déplacé pour
France Info pour engueuler les patrons
il explique que Emmanuel pardon
Elisabeth borne leur met la pression
elle multiplie les appels aux dirigeants
à la gouvernance de ces grandes
entreprises privées et disons-le qui
parfois ont juste oublié qu'on pouvait
faire des super profits des super
dividendes mais que tout le monde devait
en profiter donc j'appelle effectivement
est-ce que l'argent puisse redescendre à
celles et ceux qui le méritent amplement
autant que les gouvernants voilà ça veut
dire quoi le gouvernement est prêt à
céder à CGT
pas vraiment je crois ni à la nups ni à
la CGT en tout cas Philippe Martinez
n'était évidemment pas dupe de ses
déclarations
matinales il dit que si le gouvernement
voulait vraiment améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français plutôt que de
montrer du doigt les grands patrons il
pourrait commencer par prendre des
initiatives lui-même d'ailleurs à la CGT
on a pas mal d'idées de ce point de vue
on écoute un ministre de l'économie qui
ne sait pas ce que c'est que les super
profits qui aujourd'hui hier a dit il
faut augmenter les salaires mises de
l'Intérieur qui dit la même chose et qui
dit mais c'est pas à l'état de le faire
nous on répète le minimum que puisse
faire l'état c'est augmenter le SMIC par
la loi et mettre en place l'échelle
mobile des salaires donc on est quand
même pas d'accord entre la CGT et le
gouvernement pas question pour le
gouvernement de fixer le semi qui a 2000
euros brut comme il réclame la CGT ni
même à 1600 euros net comme son
contenterait la nuit pêche et ce débat
c'est prolongé dans l'hémicycle
exactement donc du côté de la France
insoumise c'est Manuel Bompas qui s'est
emparé du micro pour apostropher le
gouvernement pour interroger en fait de
la gouvernement et il voulait accentuer
ça sur la marche et la grève et puis
voilà comment il a commencé son
allocution aujourd'hui a lieu une
journée de grève nationale pour
l'augmentation des salaires elle fait
suite aux formidable succès de la marche
contre la vie chère organisée dimanche
dernier alors là il y a une petite
rumeur dans les musiques parce qu'on se
dit mais alors le formidable succès de
cette marche manifestement manuel
Bompard n'a pas écouté RTL pour se faire
une idée sur le succès puisque sur RTL
on disait exactement l'inverse on disait
qu'en fait cette marche était plutôt un
échec et que c'était une sorte de Chine
bon mélangeant alors même sur France
Info on est quand même un peu plus à
gauche on va dire que sur RTL sans dire
que c'est un échec vous voyez le chiffre
qui est repris c'est celui de 30000
personnes et non pas les 140 000
revendiqués par la nupes donc la marche
n'était pas un formidable succès
moi ce que je constate c'est que
dimanche quand il était à la tribune
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il était vraiment
très offensif on avait le sentiment que
on était à l'orée d'une semaine ou un
front populaire était en train de se
constituer capable de renverser le
gouvernement on l'écoute nous sommes en
train de dessiner
nouveau franc populaire qui exercera le
pouvoir dans son pays le moment venu
donc sauf qu'aujourd'hui on va dire que
l'enthousiasme était peut-être un peu
retombé puisque on a interrogé Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur cette histoire de front
qu'on pourrait constituer contre le
gouvernement et il avouer que même entre
parti politique et syndicat c'est
l'histoire de front c'est un peu
compliqué c'est pas la peine d'espérer
que à un moment donné on est une espèce
de de d'une sorte de front qui se
constituerait ouvertement parce que ça
ça n'aura pas lieu en tout cas pas tout
de suite et le gouvernement alors
comment il réagit le gouvernement là
c'était on partait des questions au
Gouvernement donc on est un peu dans la
dans la polémique on s'envoie des pics
et donc forcément Olivier du soupe un
peu ironisé sur la manière dont manuel
Bompard manier les chiffres on l'écoute
vous avez la même capacité à estimer les
participants à une manifestation qui a
estimé la réalité de la politique du
gouvernement et de ses résultats sur le
pouvoir d'achat
nous avons fait le choix je le répète de
protéger le pouvoir d'achat et d'engager
des boucliers et des mesures que aucun
autre pays en Europe n'a engagé alors là
je pense que si on avait le droit à
l'informer ce qui n'est pas encore de
risée d'avoir un PowerPoint pour appuyer
son propos là voilà le diagramme que
nous avons affiché Olivier du soft c'est
un classement ou la France est dernier
mais on peut s'en réjouir puisque c'est
en fait le pays d'Europe enfin que
l'Union européenne ou le taux
d'inflation est le plus bas mais c'est
vrai que ça pose quand même une
difficulté quand on voit la situation on
se trouve aujourd'hui parce que d'un
côté on a l'impression que le
gouvernement a prolongé la ristourne
pour calmer la grogne en même temps on
n'a pas accès à toutes les stations
essence qui ne fait qu'augmenter le
mécontentement donc est-ce que la
contagion va s'étendre alors là je vous
laisse merci
Sophie Binet pour poursuivre sur sur le
bilan de cette journée c'est c'est un
grand classique il y a toujours un très
très gros écart entre les chiffres du
ministère et c'est des et ceux des
syndicats vous diriez franchement succès
aujourd'hui quand on regarde les taux de
gré dans l'éducation nationale on est à
5,7%, un train sur deux dans les TER
Intercités le trafic des TGV quasi
normal est-ce que est-ce que c'est pas
un peu mitigé comme bilan aujourd'hui
non en fait on franchit un cap par
rapport à la mobilisation de la fin du
mois de septembre à la SNCF on était
quasiment au même niveau de grévistes on
était à 25% de taux de grévise sur la
SNCF alors qu'il y avait un périmètre
unitaire relativement restreint et ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a une colère
qui grossit avec une mobilisation qui
fait bouger les lignes parce que déjà
nous les remontées de terrain qu'on a
démontrent qui a des négociations qui
s'ouvrent qui s'amplifient dans les
entreprises avec des propositions
salariales qui commencent avec quelles
entreprises
un peu dans tous les dans tous les avant
le mouvement de conflit dans les
raffineries il y en avait beaucoup hein
oui mais
il y a des prises de conscience voilà
Air France par exemple mais il y a des
prises de conscience qui se font après
le point commun il reste très fort c'est
que systématiquement on est sur des
augmentations de salaires qui ne
permettent pas de couvrir l'inflation et
que systématiquement on a des
entreprises qui ont les moyens qui font
des profits qui distribuent des
dividendes
et donc là il faut répondre et
contrairement à ce qu'il dit le
gouvernement n'est pas impuissant
puisqu'il peut agir sur le SMIC et sûr
il peut mettre en place une échelle
mobile
en même temps que les prix il peut faire
beaucoup simplement l'état d'esprit de
la CGT ce soir bon le bilan est positif
on a compris est-ce que vous appelez
vous Sophie Binet de la CGT a reconduire
à poursuivre est-ce que vous allez
discuter dans dans vos âgés d'une autre
date pour l'instant on temporise
donc moi évidemment je décide rien toute
seule c'est les salariés qui décident en
bas de même quand ils sont engagés dans
la grève et puis la CGT va se réunir
avec les autres organisations syndicales
puisqu'on n'était pas seuls à appeler à
cette journée il y avait fort ouvrière
solidaire l'avait fait et puis une
intercer syndicale qui s'élargit parce
que dans certains secteurs il y avait la
CFDT qui pouvait appeler ou l'une ça et
donc on va travailler demain et
après-demain et proposer d'autres dates
et des perspectives à cette mobilisation
c'est compliqué toujours les chiffres
vous n'êtes pas un peu déçu mais alors
absolument pas ce qui concerne la
manifestation la marche de dimanche et
l'été aujourd'hui voit que nous avons
coup sur coup de très fortes
mobilisations le chiffre de 30000 est
absolument ridicule en réalité dès la
veille le même l'avant veille ça avait
été balancé par par le gouvernement donc
évidemment ils sont restés sur 30000
quoi qu'il arrive nous avons été au
contraire très surpris de la
mobilisation très jeune très diverses on
va venir on va vous montrer un portage
sur la composition des voilà les cortège
donc voilà donc au contraire je pense
que en plus il y a une articulation
entre d'un côté des mobilisations le
week-end un peu différent de celle qui
avait aujourd'hui des travailleurs et
travailleurs à l'appel des syndicats il
y a pour moi une complémentarité entre
les deux et je le redis il y a les
retraites il y a la réforme des
retraites qui arrivent contre laquelle
sont 60 % des Français sont contre cette
réforme et le report de trois ans de
l'âge légal de de départ en retraite et
voilà les mobilisations vont monter non
seulement sur les salaires parce que ça
a été dit on a un effondrement des
salaires réels aujourd'hui effondrement
des salaires on va venir en plus on a
des des réformes des régressions
sociales à venir très important j'aurais
terminé le tour de table sur le
diagnostic qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
dans la rue aujourd'hui Louis Marguerite
vous êtes vous êtes soulagé vous vous
dites c'est pas l'agrégation des
mécontents de tous ordres sur la vie
chère qu'on a vu cet après-midi
nous sommes pas soulagés de voir que les
gens sont mécontents et qui a une kiki
qui a en effet effectivement des colères
qui se manifestent qui existaient
d'ailleurs qui existait d'ailleurs en
revanche donc c'est un avertissement ce
soir pour vous d'abord c'est je sais pas
si c'est un avertissement ce qui est
important c'est d'abord de mettre fort
blocage parce que ça les Français et moi
j'ai énormément de de personnes dans ma
circonscription y compris des salariés y
compris certains qui sont sensibles à
vos discours parce que vous entendez
on continue mais je sais pas donc on
peut le dire qui me supplie de pouvoir
enfin de faire en sorte qu'on puisse
remettre de l'essence dans leur véhicule
et ça ce sont y compris des salariés y
compris des patrouilles beaucoup
d'indépendants aussi des professionnels
libéraux des infirmières des
sages-femmes à domicile etc qui sont
partout en France et ces cas dans ma
circonscription j'ai pas doute que c'est
le cas dans les vôtres et ailleurs qui
me demande de faire en sorte de pouvoir
de pouvoir ils ne peuvent pas se
permettre en fait de faire ces mêmes
blocages
vous pouvez je pense que entendre ça
parce que ça fait quand même plusieurs
semaines de galère ce soir la CGT
continue les blocages dans la plupart
des raffineries Total énergie et les
Français très clairement ne comprennent
plus cette position on le voit bien dans
les sondages d'abord on ne fait pas de
blocage on fait grève ensuite ça me fait
plaisir à personne de faire grève ce que
je rappelle qu'on perd un jour de
salaire enfin
je précise et nous on demande à négocier
avec la direction totale sur des
propositions sous la pression toujours
bien sûr puisque quand il y avait même
pas de négociation en fait et grâce à la
grève il y a une première séance de
négociation mais qui permet même pas de
rattraper le niveau de l'inflation donc
il faut la réouvrir immédiatement des
négociations et augmenter les salaires
au niveau de l'inflation on va parler
des entreprises les plus riches de
France quand même on va parler des
moyens de meilleurs moyens pour parvenir
à des augmentations salaires dans les
entreprises c'est les entreprises les
salariés qui décident c'est pas l'état a
priori même si l'État peut faire
pression bonsoir Sylvain boulot et merci
d'avoir patienté vous êtes historien
spécialiste des mouvements sociaux à
quoi on assiste là c'est un mouvement
social est-ce qu'on peut le dire c'est
un mouvement syndical qui peut enfin des
grèves qui peuvent déboucher sur un
mouvement social d'envergure pour
l'instant on en est pas là on en est pas
là ça peut ça peut ne jamais on en est
au balbutie de
mobilisation sur un mot d'ordre qui est
à peu près général qui est une
augmentation de 10% des salaires au
niveau au niveau national comprennent
toutes les branches et toutes les
catégories ça suit professionnel c'est
quelque chose qui a même été encouragé
par le gouvernement puisqu'il
gouvernement a dit il faut que les
entreprises augmentent les salaires donc
on est dans une grogne générale de
l'ensemble des salariés qui espère
obtenir une augmentation importante pour
compenser pour compenser
de rien puisque si on prend les
mouvements des grands mouvements de
grève historiques on n'est pas du tout
là et on n'est pas dans du tout non plus
dans la même conjoncture
l'évolution c'est que le type de grève
jusqu'à maintenant et puis une trentaine
d'années on était plutôt principalement
dans des grèves défensives c'est-à-dire
pour la défense des conquêtes sociales
retraite etc etc et là on est en train
de changer de nature de grève puisqu'on
est dans des grèves offensives puisque
les salariés commencent à réclamer des
augmentations de salaire ce qui ne
s'était pas vu depuis le début des
années 80 on pratiquement avec
je vous propose une chose je vous donne
la parole dans un instant mais
j'aimerais qu'on les entendent chanter
c'est manifestant c'est Léo ce qui s'est
promené dans le cortège parisien on va
tout de suite essayer de comprendre si
oui ou non et bien il y a suffisamment
de profil pour parler de mouvement
social et puis est-ce qu'il y a vraiment
une agrégation des mécontents regardez
tous ensemble c'était le slogan d'un
cortège parisien très éclectique ou côte
à côte on défilé étudiant travailleur et
retraités parmi eux Ludovic 30 ans
cheminot pour la SNCF venu par
solidarité soutenir les grévistes
réquisitionnés des raffineries et
réclamer un salaire plus élevé
faut pas trop plusieurs fois des
augmentations
on s'est fait mettre à la porte
maintenant la seule solution cap pour
nous c'est la grève et plus d'unité
viendra nous rejoindre plus on aura de
quoi pour que tous les Français puissent
avoir une augmentation salariale une
hausse de salaire pour faire face à
l'inflation c'est aussi ce qui espère
Benoît menzon 46 ans chimiste chez
Thalès ça fait trois années de suite où
on assure pas le long de coup de la vie
donc ça fait trois années de suite qu'on
perd du salaire et donc au bout d'un
moment on peut que dire STOP surtout
quand on voit autant d'argent engrangé
par nos grands industriels c'est pas
possible faut qu'il y ait une
répartition des richesses une
préoccupation qui concerne aussi les
retraités comme Yvette 71 ans qui
s'inquiète davantage pour sa fille quand
je vois mes enfants j'ai deux enfants
que ma fille me dit 1800 euros elle est
en à 6 ans maternelle elle me dit maman
mon salaire il est moine ta pension
alors comment j'étais administratif à la
RATP c'est pas normal dans le cortège
mêlé au salarié des étudiants de lycée
professionnel mais également à
l'université comme poli et Sacha 20 et
18 ans qui prône la convergence des
luttes
à tous les mouvements ouvriers parce que
au final ce pourquoi on se base c'est
toujours la même chose c'est plus d'aide
plus d'écoute autant en tant qu'étudiant
et qu'en tant que futur travailleur
parce que pour le moment on est étudiant
mais on va aussi intégrer le monde du
travail à la fin de nos études et toute
notre cause au final elle est commune
aujourd'hui en France 300 000 personnes
ont défilé selon la CGT ils étaient
107000 pour le ministère de l'Intérieur
[Musique]
vous disiez en regardant ce sujet que là
il y a un salarié du privé qui témoigne
qu'ils étaient ils étaient très très
nombreux d'entreprises mariées et une
grande diversité par exemple il y avait
des soignants et des soignantes de
Corian qui dénonçaient la stagnation de
leur groupe privé il y avait aussi un
petit EHPAD privé par exemple qui
s'appelle l'EHPAD de Neville dans le 95
qui me racontait que chez elle la NAO
c'est gala zéro parce qu'il y a même pas
négociation alors qu'il y a des profits
très importants il y avait les apaves
c'est un institut de contrôle et de
certification en termes de sécurité qui
était là et qui expliquait qu'il y avait
de plus de salariés que d'habitude dans
la grève j'ai aussi vu donc vous vous
avez vu voilà c'était vous avez vu des
salariés de secteurs très différents
avec un mot d'ordre commun les salaires
Louis Marguerite il y a il y a quand
même quelque chose qui qui pose question
c'est cette loi pouvoir d'achat au à
l'été que vous avez eu ou le
gouvernement a très clairement plutôt
favoriser les primes et non pas les
augmentations de salaire même si il y a
eu le dégel du point d'indice mais qui
vient après de nombreuses années de gel
est-ce que vous avez pas au fond la
mauvaise stratégie plus qu'Auto que
d'inciter vraiment de faire en sorte
vraiment que la valeur soit partagée que
les salaires soient augmentés vous allez
plutôt orienter même si c'est pas vous
qui fixez les règles mais la prime
plutôt que la housse de salaire d'abord
il faut pas il faut pas donner
l'impression qu'on a rien fait peut-être
qu'on a que c'est pas assez sans doute
j'ai encore une fois on peut en discuter
et voilà mais néanmoins vous avez montré
le graphique on a l'impression la plus
basse d'Europe c'est à dire que tout est
parfait loin loin sans faute et ça veut
dire que ce qui ressenti par nos
concitoyens et c'est représentatif de la
réalité bien sûr que c'est dur et moi on
a tous dans nos circonscriptions des
gens et ça fait longtemps et ça fait pas
depuis le mois de juillet ça fait déjà
avant la guerre en Ukraine c'était le
cas avec le prix de l'alimentaire qui
avait déjà commencé à augmenter ensuite
je pense que ce qui est montré dans
votre portage ce qui est des solutions
assez différentes il y a des grandes
entreprises privées et là et d'ailleurs
c'est le Bruno Le Maire comme j'ai un
lama n'en n'allait pas attendu
aujourd'hui ou hier pour le dire on
avait déjà commencé à dire il faut que
il faut que ce soit que ce soit discuté
et beaucoup de l'augmentation de salaire
oui bien sûr mais moi je peux aussi vous
citer le cas de beaucoup de
d'entreprises de lettres de restauration
de restaurant de café d'hôtels qui ont
commencé à augmenter leur salaire non
seulement parce qu'il y avait de
l'inflation mais aussi parce que il
n'arrivait pas à recruter donc ils ont
été obligés d'augmenter et ça et donc
effectivement le le rythme
d'augmentation de salaire et peut-être
pas suffisant pour pour beaucoup et je
veux bien l'entendre en revanche à
nouveau la discussion bien sûr la
négociation même si elle est parfois
tendue c'est respectable et moi il se
trouve dans mes fonctions d'avant
j'avais déjà eu le cas de j'avais déjà
eu des négociations parfois difficiles
mais le blocage ça c'est pas possible et
ça ça vient pénaliser énormément notre
tissu économique qui est très divers 96%
des entreprises françaises ont moins de
20 salariés on l'oublie trop souvent et
c'est ça qu'il faut mettre en valeur
c'est pas des blocages c'est des grèves
et comme il y a beaucoup de grévis il se
trouve que ça gêne que ça gêne mais oui
comme il y a beaucoup de grèves je vais
vous dire pourquoi c'est pas un blocage
c'est qu'en fait il y a une majorité de
grévistes d'ailleurs quand quand votre
quand le ministre de l'Économie dit
c'est une grève illégitime ce qui pour
moi est absolument scandaleux c'est une
grève illégitime alors qu'il y a une
majorité de grévistes dans dans ces
entreprises
il y a une majorité de grève sinon sinon
effectivement ça ne gênerait pas comme
ça donc la première chose je vous ai pas
couper s'il vous plaît deuxième chose
sur la loi pouvoir d'achat vous avez
tout fait tout fait pour ne jamais
augmenter les salaires vous avez
repoussé toutes nos propositions
d'augmentation du SMIC tout ce qui
pouvait ressembler de près ou de loin à
une augmentation de salaire cet
après-midi encore vous avez vu je vais
vous dire l'amendement que vous avez
repoussé vous et le rassemblement
national la droite et l'extrême droite
ensemble une un amendement pour faire un
encadrement des revenus dans les
entreprises alors quand je vois monsieur
Darmanin dire ah c'est dommage chez
grand patron qui gagne tant oh c'est
dommage ces ouvriers qui gagnent si peu
et bien légiféron un état qui est au
service du bien-être général
illégifèrement des salaires dans les
entreprises il est possible des salaires
des hauts dirigeants aujourd'hui Patrick
pouyanet je vous donne la parole tout de
suite après a fait connaître au bout
d'une longue polémique sur son
augmentation de 50% son salaire annuel 5
millions
444129 euros par an et il a un petit
graphique pour expliquer que au fond
l'année 2020 ce n'était que du
rattrapage parce que covid oblige
l'activité totale énergie avait
énormément baissé on est dans on est
dans le symbole mais vous savez à quel
point les symboles c'est important
est-ce qu'il y a pas une réponse alors
soit sur l'encadrement des des salaires
au sein de l'entreprise et notamment
celui des revenus soit sur la taxation
des super confiés à apporter non mais le
tweet de Patrick poignée je peux
comprendre qu'il est né mais ça n'engage
ni le gouvernement ni la majorité
c'est une entreprise privée non mais je
voulais compléter la question d'Aurélie
trouver son encadrement des salaires par
rapport à ça c'est une entreprise privée
il rendait compte à son conseil
d'administration et son assemblée
générale et le cas échéance est salarié
s'ils sont s'ils sont membres du conseil
je là dessus encore une fois
vous êtes vous êtes de formation
économique si j'ai bien compris c'est
pas ça peut pas être dans l'économie
dirigée où on fixe ses salaires on écrit
que ben on va tous ces augmenter de 5%,
10% etc mais ouais ou administrés qu'on
voulait quoi elle est très régulier
notre économie et il s'agit pas Morgan
donc vous pouvez pas dire du jour au
lendemain et bien on augmente tous les
salaires on l'a fait on l'a fait pour la
fonction publique en déjanté on l'a
augmenté le SMIC européen vous le savez
on est le seul pays européen avoir des
revalorisations qui sont infrastruelles
on est quasiment entre celle de janvier
et celle de là pratiquement au niveau de
l'inflation je peux comprendre
je peux comprendre que ce soit par
ressenti ça je veux bien entendre et moi
j'en ai j'en ai qui me le dis dans ma
circonscriptions entreprises que moins
de 20 salariés alors dirigeant et alors
ça dirigeant qui parfois sont payés
moins que leur salarié parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas se peuvent pas se payer
autant et c'est comme ça de leur dire
bah du jour au lendemain vous allez
augmenter de 5 ou 10 % sans qu'on vous
coupe
quels sont les leviers que l'État mais
moi je vais vous faire écouter Laurent
Berger et je vous donne 62 look la
parole juste après parce que lui n'était
pas dans les cortèges la CFDT n'a pas
appelé à faire la grève aujourd'hui
parce qu'il considère que ce n'est pas
la bonne méthode pour obtenir des
entreprises une augmentation salaire
écoutez le patron de la CFDT il était
l'invité d'audition publique hier sur
LCP la journée de demain et l'invisent
les salariés de son côté et
l'invisibilise les salariés et les EHPAD
elle invisibilise laissez-moi finir s'il
vous plaît elle invisibilise les
salariés de Groupama tout vous savez
pourquoi parce qu'on va pas en parler
demain faire croire que l'action
syndicale pour l'augmentation des
salaires c'est d'organiser des grandes
manifestations interprofessionnelles je
vais vous dire
non je vais vous dire les salariés n'y
croient pas
voilà Laurent Berger qui explique que
c'est pas comme ça qu'on obtient des
augmentations réelles de salaire si les
hommes c'est la stratégie de la CFDT qui
est de dire on va dans la négociation et
c'est par la négociation qu'on obtiendra
des salaires il peut se trouver des cas
où il y a pas de négociation et que les
salariés sont obligés de tenir de se
mobilier sous d'autres formes et encore
si on est bien des femmes tout à fait
légales et tout à fait normal de
mobilisation qui sont la grève il y a
pas de sabotage il y a pas de il y a pas
de il y a pas d'usine mollets on est
resté dans le cadre tout à fait légal je
voudrais même revenir sur un point qui
est parce que vous parlez
systématiquement de l'accord
d'entreprise l'accord d'entreprise ça
touche toute l'entreprise donc ça veut
dire tous les salariés de cette
entreprise ont voté y compris les y
compris les cadres de l'entreprise quand
on regarde par contre les gens qui sont
mobilisés c'est pas exactement les mêmes
puisque ceux qui se sont mobilisés et
qui sont toujours en grève aujourd'hui
c'est ceux qui participent de l'appareil
de production donc il aurait fallu dans
ce cas là si on veut des accords
d'entreprises qui représentent
réellement les intérêts
des salariés il faudrait faire voter
ceux qui sont réellement concernés par
par les moteurs de grève et pas faire
pas l'ensemble dans l'entreprise parce
que ça décale les choses c'est comme si
vous faisiez voter
enfin Sophie Binet pour répondre à
Laurent Berger lui dit au fond
l'efficacité c'est pas ça l'efficacité
c'est au niveau de la branche au niveau
de l'activité économique d'une
entreprise la négociation oui sauf que
la négociation elle fonctionne seulement
avec le rapport de force en fait ça fait
10 mois qu'on demande partout dans
toutes les entreprises des négociations
pour que les salaires soient quand même
oui il y en a
pas déjà et puis dans les endroits où il
y en a dans les opérations les
augmentations sont inférieures à
l'inflation et donc aujourd'hui on
assiste à un déclassement massif les
chiffres du ministère du travail sont
clairs les cadres par exemple en un an
ont perdu 3,6% de salaire donc on voit
qu'il y a un tassement sans précédent
prioritaires c'est les cadres
prioritaires enfin tous les salariés
moins pénalisant de leurs qualités
2,2% de salaire pour les employés ces
2,6% de salaire en baisse donc on voit
qu'on a un tassement massif un
déclassement massif qui s'organise
derrière faut pas s'étonner de pas
réussir à recruter et avoir des
qualifications pour l'avenir et donc
négocier oui mais avec du rapport de
force et c'est ça qui fait bouger les
livres et dans toutes les boîtes j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de Groupama de
Corian qui était dans les cortèges et
c'est là la grève et la manifestation
qui fait bouger la Ligue incompréhendent
leurs entreprises les solutions les
députés on est à l'Assemblée nationale
donc c'est à cet amendement refusé si
j'ai bien compris sur l'encadrement des
des salaires dans l'entreprise le SMIC
on va pas refaire le débat ça aussi le
gouvernement dit que c'est un frein à
l'embauche qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
d'autre pourquoi par exemple indexer le
les salaires sur l'inflation c'est ce
que réclame François Ruffin tout
simplement parce que c'est c'est ce que
porte la CG j'étais tout simplement
parce que vous êtes économiste et vous
entendez les économistes qui parlent de
spirale en fait d'abord il y a pas de
spirale je peux vous dire que tous les
économistes un peu sérieux aujourd'hui
disent qu'il n'y a pas aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle une boucle inflation
salaire du tout au contraire on a un
décrochage des salaires par rapport à
l'envoler des prix ce qui se passe de
manière globale parce qu'on peut prendre
telle ou tel exemple c'est plus 6% de
prix pour les prix en un an d'accord
plus 12 % sur l'alimentation je prends
cet exemple parce que ça veut dire qu'en
fait pour les ménages modeste
l'inflation ressente subit elle est
encore beaucoup plus importante que
c'est plus 6 % et une hausse moyenne je
vais dire en moyenne de 3% des salaires
voilà le résultat de l'impuissance de
l'état de des non décision
donc il faut un revenir à une indexation
des salaires une échelle mobile des
salaires d'ailleurs c'est le cas c'est
le cas en Belgique deux hausse du SMIC à
1600 euros net nous c'est ce qu'on porte
alors évidemment on peut avoir des des
estimations différentes nous on estime
que en dessous de 1600 euros net en tout
cas on ne vit pas dignement alors qu'on
travaille à taux plein voilà et ensuite
il y a d'autres propositions notamment
des conférences annualisées générale sur
les salaires qui sont même portés
parfois par des membres de la minorité
présidentielle comme quoi comme quoi non
là vous êtes minoritaire dans
l'assemblée la preuve c'est que vous
allez utiliser à 49,3
parler à l'envie il y a des des articles
de la littérature qui disent que il peut
y avoir des effets inflationnistes
d'autres noms donc on peut en parler à
l'envie je pense que c'est pas l'objet
de ce débat mais vous pas à chaque fois
à chaque fois vous avez l'air il y a
deux propositions
que vous puissiez dire que c'est pas
assez je veux bien l'entendre qu'il
faille dépenser plus qu'il soit
peut-être mais néanmoins c'est comme si
on avait on avait on est le seul pays
d'Europe mais vraiment d'Europe sans
doute du monde à avoir fait ce qu'on a
fait avec une bouclier énergétique qui
touche très directement et ça on n'a pas
attendu d'ailleurs le mois de juillet
puisque c'était déjà le cas entre
janvier et juin et je viens de le
gouvernement on est sur l'indexation
pourquoi pour vous ça n'est pas la bonne
piste d'indexer les salaires sur
l'inflation imposer peut-être que sur
certaines entreprises ça pourrait
éventuellement marcher
sans doute mais peut-être que ça
pourrait marcher sur cette entreprise
mais je suis persuadé qu'ils ont des
situations extrêmement diverses
extrêmement hétéro des jeunes il y a
effectivement des secteurs qui se
portent bien d'autres à l'inverse qui se
portent mal parce que et moi je suis sûr
que si on remplace une telle solution on
va aller voir dans deux trois quatre
mois des masses salariales qui vont
considérablement augmenter dans des
secteurs ou c'est plus difficile où il y
a besoin d'investissement dans les
usines où on a besoin de changer sa
machine pour maintenir l'emploi donc il
faut laisser un peu souplesse à
l'entreprise parce que ça ne se décrète
pas et en effet il faut que vous c'était
la question que vous aviez posé juste
avant c'est comment on fait on crée
toutes les conditions pour permettre aux
chefs d'entreprise aux dirigeants et à
permettre cette augmentation cette
augmentation de salaire Sophie Binet
vous aurez le mot de la fin ok fait des
bacs c'est que les dividendes ont
explosé de 33% cette année et il y a une
chose qu'il faut arrêter c'est
d'instrumentaliser les petites
entreprises pour cacher les profits des
grosses le gouvernement l'état donne
chaque année 150 milliards d'euros
d'aide publique aux entreprises qui sont
ni conditionnées ni évaluées ces aides
publiques c'est un levier pour
transformer l'économie vous pourriez
tout à fait par exemple les cibler pour
les petites entreprises alors qu'elles
sont captées par les grosses et du coup
mettre des conditions en matière
environnementales en matière salariale
et puis la dernière chose la réforme des
retraites il faut y renoncer on est dans
un contexte explosif arrêtez la
provocation nous inviterai la prochaine
fois pour en parler c'est sûr qu'on va
reparler des retraites en tout cas les
pistes sont sur la table on est encore
en plein débats budgétaires pour combien
de temps le 49,3 c'est sûrement pour
demain on verra ce qu'il en est de ce
49-3 si les il y a quelques mesures
symboliques sur sur les super dividendes
seront dans le projet de loi une finnée
retenue ou pas merci beaucoup à faire à
suivre donc merci à vous d'avoir
participé à ce débat on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin il vient nous
parler de Pierre Mendès France dont on
célèbre aujourd'hui le 40e anniversaire
de la mort il nous fait découvrir vous
allez le voir à un autre PMF intime
romanesque passionné de généalogie et
surtout viscéralement attaché à
démontrer qu'il n'avait en rien jurpé
son nom comme tant d'antisémite l'ont
accusé Mendès la France est un film
France Télévisions Yves jelland la
réaliser avec Alex Morin on en parle
avec lui juste après l'invitation de
Marco 1er
si on vous invite Yves Jaulin c'est pour
votre documentaire sur Pierre Mendès
France dont on célèbre aujourd'hui les
40 ans de sa disparition l'occasion pour
vous et Alix Morin de revenir sur la vie
de cet homme d'État figure de la
Quatrième République un documentaire
intime grâce à des archives inédites
transmises par sa famille c'était
vraiment comme une malle au trésor toute
sa vie il a documenté
tout ce qu'il vivait chronologiquement
minutieusement Yves gelant vous êtes
auteur et réalisateur de documentaires
pour le grand écran et la petite lucarne
à votre compteur une trentaine de films
vous aimez mettre en lumière les
artistes Gabin Chaplin mais aussi les
politiques comme Georges Frêche ou
François Hollande aujourd'hui vous nous
faites découvrir un autre Pierre Mendès
France une vie romanesque rocambolesque
profondément patriote Vichy l'accusera
pourtant de désertion en 1940 condamné
il s'échappera de prison dans cet
archive il revient sur son procès les
gens
qui souhaitait la condamnation cruelle
qui était désolé que je sois pas fusillé
tout de suite qui qui regrette même
qu'on donne la parole pour me défendre
Pierre Mendès France une figure de la
gauche au service de son pays
député plusieurs fois ministres et
brièvement président du Conseil sous une
quatrième République instable un
Français juif cible d'attaque
antisémites Haillie par certains parfois
hués comme sur ces images en 1967
lorsqu'il tente de revenir dans le jeu
politique c'est vrai que j'ai été très
violemment attaqué il y a eu des
attentats contre moi enfin je si nous
regardons ce qui s'est passé depuis un
siècle Enfin les hommes de la gauche les
hommes du progrès ont toujours susciter
des résistances passion Jules Ferry Léon
Blum Jean et Salengro d'autres que
j'oublie et j'ai pris la suite de cette
filiation une filiation avec les grands
noms de la gauche d'où cette question ce
soir Yves jelland vous qui avez le goût
de la politique dites nous qui est le
dîner ritier de Pierre Mendès France
bonsoir Yvon et merci d'être là Mendes
la France commentaire lu par le comédien
Mathieu Amalric diffusé ce week-end sur
France 5 le film est toujours disponible
en replay sur les plateformes de France
Télévisions alors Mendes c'est l'homme
du devoir c'est l'homme de la vertu par
excellence c'est le refus de biaiser
c'est le refus de transiger qui peut
prétendre après lui a-t-il un héritier
aujourd'hui
il faut chercher il faut chercher
longtemps un
héritier jeune je dirais que c'est
compliqué
la filiation de Mendès France bon il
faut chercher à gauche parce que si on
doit chercher un nouveau Mendes Mendès a
toujours été fidèle à la gauche la
gauche a été moins fidèle à Mendes que
lui n'a été fidèle à la gauche donc si
on cherche à gauche dans sa filiation
mais je vais pas vous dire le nouveau
puisqu'il est mort c'était Michel Rocard
aujourd'hui c'est difficile à dire
honnêtement un jeune Mendès aujourd'hui
dans la stature de morale même s'il
vient pas de la deuxième gauche on
pourrait citer Lionel Jospin comme
personne retirée de la vie publique dans
l'exigence morale quelqu'un qui sait pas
accroché au pouvoir et là vous me prenez
un peu
à froid je dis peut-être Bertrand
delanoué Bertrand delanoué effectivement
on n'a pas voulu voilà je pense
ça ne ça ne colle pas vraiment non ce
serait intéressant parce que aujourd'hui
il y avait un hommage aux Invalides
d'Emmanuel Macron pour les combattants
et anciens combattants Jerry des 60 ans
de l'indépendance Mendès lui il a refusé
de cautionner la torture et il est parti
Emmanuel Macron lui aussi il a un peu de
main d'oeuf non il est contre les corps
intermédiaires enfin en tout cas les
corporative contre la rente
rien à voir
dans une ambition personnelle qu'elle
n'avait pas mal de France c'est
formidable comme tout le monde se
réclame de Mendès France aujourd'hui
enfin les morts sont tous des braves
types comme disait Georges Brassens donc
faut pas oublier que Mendes même si elle
était toujours très populaire qui n'a
jamais été un homme politique marginal
il était quand même souvent minoritaire
il était minoritaire à l'intérieur de
son parti le Parti radical il était
minoritaire dans la gauche donc
aujourd'hui on le trouve formidable mais
honnêtement du côté de Macron comme
c'est l'homme du en même temps il dit
qu'il a en même temps de Gaulle et en
même temps mendèse donc même si les deux
hommes sont retrouvés ensemble à Londres
pendant la guerre
Mendes c'est vous proposer à de Gaulle
donc c'est difficile d'être à la fois
main desiste égoïste et je pense surtout
que la vision verticale jupitérienne du
pouvoir
Macron macroniste ou macronien se marie
assez peu avec la vision de Mendès
France cette phrase dans le film contre
l'élection du président du suffrage
universel à part Michel Rocard il y a eu
très peu d'hommes politiques qui sont
dit contre l'élection du président du
président suffrage universel direct
contre une constitution écrite sur
mesure pour pour le général celui qui
qui a combattu contre le coup d'état
permanent François Mitterrand dès qui
s'est retrouvé à la tête du pouvoir et
qu'il est arrivé au château à l'Élysée
il s'est très très bien il sait très
bien
il a cette phrase Mendès France dans le
film je n'ai jamais eu cette qualité
quelle habilité en politique labilité ou
le machiavélisme c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'il n'a pas d'héritiers d'ailleurs
alors votre film nous fait découvrir un
Mendès France généalogiste
qui écrit qui concerne qui collectionne
et qui avait cette passion de remonter
aux origines de son nom Mendès France ce
nom français d'origine portugaise que
tant d'antisémites ont voulu lui retirer
et il conservait un arbre c'est une
révélation que vous faites dans ce film
racontez-moi un arbre dessiné manuscrit
oui il y a beaucoup de révélations moi
je me passionne pour Mendès France
depuis que je suis étudiant ça fait
partie de mes références à autant le
dire tout de suite le vraiment le le
confesser mais c'est vrai que
j'imaginais pas que cet homme si pudique
avait passé sa vie à documenter sa
propre existence et notamment sa passion
pour la généalogie et ce c'est un si
beau nom Mendès France ce magnifique nom
voyez c'est trop beau pour être vrai
donc on a cessé de l'attaquer sur son
nom puisqu'on a dit mais Mendès France
c'est pas possible ce juif là il peut
pas s'appeler comme ça il s'appelle main
d'assisraël il s'appelle Mendes Cohen il
s'appelle Mendes Molina on lui a trouvé
l'extrême droite notamment disait Mendès
France les poujadistes Le Pen
une adresse et donc il a voulu vraiment
pour répondre à la haine antisémite il a
voulu défendre ce beau nom de Mendès
France et montrer qu'il ne l'avait pas
usurpé et montrer que justement c'est
ces
aïeux et alors là vraiment sur la
branche paternelle donc de père en fils
il est remonté remonté remonté déjà son
grand-père Jules avec dessiné un très
bel arbre qu'on montre dans notre film
mais ensuite John Mendès France la belle
fille de Pierre Mendès France nous a
montré Alix Morin la co-rédiatrice et à
moi-même d'autres documents formidables
évidemment ces albums de photos avec des
dizaines de milliers de photos 142
albums et un autre album comme index est
allé faire lui-même il est remontait
beaucoup plus loin jusqu'à la fin du 15e
siècle avant l'Inquisition portugaise et
puis ce cet arrière-arrière arrière
arrière arrière grand-père qui
s'appelait Louis Mendès France Luis
Mendes des Français qui arrivait à
Bordeaux en 7 4 donc voilà il a à la
fois la pression la passion de la
généalogie et et aussi le le
la manière de répondre à la haine
antisémite mais c'est vraiment d'une
violence inouïe toute sa vie il est
poursuivi par l'antisémitisme évidemment
pendant les années 30 mais après la
guerre et même dans son propre camp même
après qu'il était président du conseil
au sein du Parti radical vous montrez
des caricatures des expressions et puis
il y a le procès ça c'est
la blessure la blessure le déshonneur
racontez-nous le procès qui a lieu à
Clermont-Ferrand donc après l'affaire du
Massilia où on l'accuse d'avoir déserté
alors que c'est le procès que lui fait
Vichy c'est le procès des déserteurs qui
accuse que le camp qui justement veut
continuer à combattre et dans ce bateau
il y a également Jean Zay qui est donc
qui finira assassiner par la par la
milice et et d'autres d'autres hommes
politiques d'autres députés qui
portaient l'uniforme et ça a toujours
voulu combattre il a même souvent
devancé la paix il voulait vraiment son
corps de d'armée c'était c'était
l'aviation et d'ailleurs il finit par
rejoindre de Gaulle à Londres et même
quand vous dites que même dans son camp
on retrouvera des antisémites il en
retrouvera même au sein de la France
libre à Londres
qui est l'antimisme était là c'est une
valeur unanimant partagée à droite à
gauche il en sera même aussi victime de
d'attaque antisémites de la part du
Parti communiste français mais les
attaques viennent surtout de l'extrême
droite et c'est vrai qu'il y a ce procès
qui sera la blessure de sa vie à
Clermont-Ferrand où on l'accuse à 6 ans
d'emprisonnement pour avoir déserté
alors que c'est tout l'inverse et que le
fait même d'être accusé déserteur et
pour lui une infamie on a souillé son
nom et dit je préférerais être le que
mes enfants soient les enfants de
quelqu'un de tomber au champ d'honneur
que quelqu'un qui accusé de désertion et
comme il supporte il va obtenir la
révision quelques années après il abra
son honneur avant d'être président du
conseil il va écrire à
à
Pétain à deux reprises au maréchal pour
lui parler juste pour lui passer parler
de tous les faits on est en direct de
grave allez-y et donc et ce qui s'est
passé c'est que il a réussi à s'évader
finalement et il s'engagera dans la
Résistance une encore une évasion
rocambolesque pour ce destin romanes
vous racontez aussi Louviers sa terre
d'élection lui qui n'avait pas d'attache
avec cette Normandie il adore ses
pommiers il adore ses jardins il adore
aussi ses électeurs c'est très
intéressant de voir à quel point on peut
adopter une terre et une maison de
Louviers il y a chez Mendès France à ta
pression immense d'une occasion manquée
malgré tout malgré ces 7 mois et demi de
pouvoir regarder et écouter cet extrait
vous avez dit non au général de Gaulle
en 45 vous avez refusé votre
participation à tous les gouvernements
entre 45 et 54 vous avez démissionné du
gouvernement guimolait vous avez dit non
en général de Gaulle en 58 vous avez dit
renonce générale de Gaulle en 62 vous
avez de vous présenter en 65 et quand
vous vous êtes quand vous avez secondé
Gaston de fer c'était dans une aventure
dont vous saviez parfaitement dès le
début quel était sans issue est-ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment qu'au-delà
des raisons que vous invoquez ici là il
n'y a pas quelque chose de de profond
d'intimes d'irrationnel peut-être mais
en tout cas de décisif qui vous a
conduit à refuser votre destin au lieu
de l'accomplir
je suis très ému par cette question
peut-être sur certains points et Jules
tort de prendre des attitudes ou des
positions qui pouvaient déplaire à une
partie de l'opinion publique et surtout
certaines fractions extrêmement
dynamiques extrêmement agressives
généralement si tu as droite et à
l'extrême droite bien sûr si j'avais dit
à un moment donné il faut faire la
politique d'Algérie française il faut
écraser la rébellion ou si j'avais dit
plus tard
les circonstances étant ce qu'elles sont
j'accepte un régime politique qui donne
à l'exécutif la totalité des pouvoirs un
excès de d'autoritarisme l'excès de
monopolisation du pouvoir bien sûr
j'aurais eu l'avantage de d'avoir un
portefeuille voilà et vous aurez reconnu
autour de la table de cette interview
elle s'inclair Jean Daniel René Gérard
Schwarzenberg Roger Gérard pardonnez-moi
tous ceux qui auraient tant voulu
l'aventure politique et qu'il aille plus
haut encore
l'ange qui lui se poser la question oui
et on sent que en posant cette question
il touche à quelque chose de profond et
et anne sinclair toute jeune journaliste
on est en 1977 m'a confié que à l'issue
de ce plateau de l'homme en question
c'était le titre de son émission il est
resté longtemps de longues minutes voir
presque une demi-heure à discuter avec
Jean-Louis brolinge parce que il avait
visé juste en fait bon c'est vrai en
même temps il a laissé une trace
formidable il est assez une empreinte
François Mitterrand a dit le jour des
obsèques de Mendès France qui s'était un
éveillard de conscience bon il a pas
vraiment éveillé la conscience de
François Mitterrand ça c'est une autre
chose mais en tout cas il a marqué des
générations et des générations et on le
voit avec Alix Morin qu'on est allé
présenter le film à Paris à Bordeaux
Pessac Louviers combien il a laissé une
trace dans la mémoire des gens alors
peut-être pas dans les mémoires des des
enfants aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas de
verre de lait à boire à la récréation
mais en tout cas dans beaucoup de
générations et puis c'est une histoire
de transmission moi j'avais à peine 13
ans quand il est 14 ans quand il est
mort et en même temps sa figure ne m'a
jamais quitté la France est toujours
dans quelques mois on verra ça merci
beaucoup vous restez avec moi Yves je
lent pour les affranchis on va les
accueillir pour leur partie prix ce soir
la chronique parlementaire d'Elsa
mondingueva le 49-3 peut en cacher un
autre on va le voir dans un instant
l’œil sur l'Europe de Richard Werly les
pistes de l'Union pour réduire les prix
de l'énergie et puis le parti pris
deftel la loi climat contre la
bétonisation des avouées par les mers
nos affranchis les voici bonsoir à vous
trois bonsoir ravi de vous accueillir
particulièrement Richard que j'ai pas vu
depuis longtemps allez on commence avec
Elsa alors elle va vous parler du 49-3
le 49.3 ou les 49,3 j'y comprends plus
rien bah les 49-3 je vous en mets deux
pour le prix d'un ce soir alors tout
d'abord Myriam on en a beaucoup parlé on
l'attend c'est celui qui va arriver sur
le projet de loi de finances sauf énorme
surprise ça devrait être demain reste
encore l'horaire à trancher alors on
sait que la première ministre Elisabeth
borne elle sera au Sénat à 15h pour la
séance de gouvernement elle pourrait
donc être autour de 17h ici à
l'Assemblée pour annoncer le 49.3 à
moins et bien que le gouvernement décide
d'aller au bout du temps prévu c'est à
dire pardon Jean-Pierre mon micro minuit
demain soir Michel Rocard en octobre
1989 lui il l'avait annoncé à 6h40 du
matin donc on sait comment ça va se
terminer depuis le début d'ailleurs par
le 49-3 après le 49-3 il y aura
d'émotion de censure oui il y en aura
deux celle de la gauche la nupes et puis
celle du rassemblement national a priori
on fera donc bande à part même si
c'était pas forcément prévu comme ça au
départ mais Marine Le Pen l'a bien redit
tout à l'heure elle ne votera pas la
motion de la nuit écoutez il n'y aurait
aucun sens à ce que nous votions une
motion de censure qui est fondée sur des
éléments politiques qui sont exactement
l'inverse de ce que nous-mêmes nous
reprochons au gouvernement bon la
réciproque devrait être vrai chez la
nupes et il y a maintenant une chose qui
va jouer c'est quelle motion on va
débattre et voter en premier est-ce que
c'est celle qui sera déposée en premier
il y aura une course de vitesse ou celle
qui aura le plus de signataires il y a
pas vraiment de jurisprudence à
l'Assemblée donc si la nuit pèse veut
être sûr que la sienne soit discutée en
premier il faut se dépêcher pour la
déposer en premier puisqu'ils sont plus
nombreux car rassemblement national ça
ce sera samedi ou lundi et alors
j'apprends que ce n'est pas le seul 49 3
de la semaine oui puisqu'à partir de
jeudi 9h les députés examinent le budget
de la Sécurité sociale alors pourquoi
peut-il y avoir un 49,3 assez rapidement
déjà il y a une question assez technique
sur le budget on discute des recettes et
puis 10 jours plus tard dans une partie
bien séparée on discute des dépenses là
dans le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale les dépenses et les
recettes elles s'enchaînent sauf que
s'il y a un risque et bien qu'on adopte
pas les recettes le gouvernement
n'hésitera pas à dégainer assez
rapidement le 49-3 il y a aussi un
autrice c'est que le gouvernement soit
encore à nouveau mis en minorité et puis
il y a aussi une petite exaspération des
députés de la majorité qu'on demandait
que ça aille un petit peu plus vite pour
les autres textes certains disent il ne
faut pas nous faire toute la nuit si à
la fin on conclut pas donc le
gouvernement est prévenu pour les
prochains textes 49-3 vendredi c'est ça
sur le PLFSS sur le budget de la Sécu en
plus après ou jeudi il y a plusieurs
centaines d'amendements à débattre mais
a priori ça pourrait être oui jeudi soir
vendredi dans la journée vous la
regardez cette nouvelle Assemblée vous
adorez la politique le 49-3 est-ce que
ça peut être compris dans la nouvelle
donne qu'on connaît aujourd'hui au
Palais Bourbon par les Français ou c'est
toujours un peu un passage en force et
un gros un gros bobo à la démocratie
d'abord le PLFSS j'ai du mal à
comprendre déjà donc
je connais parce que évidemment je
regarde
c'est toujours le le dilemme et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce que on
avance ou est-ce que ou est-ce que je
suis plutôt contente de la manière dont
est constituée cette nouvelle Assemblée
même si j'aurais souhaité qui est
évidemment moins de députés
rassemblement national et dans
département de l'Aude où je suis né il y
a quand même trois
députés sur trois qui sont rassemblement
national et ça j'aurais souhaité une
autre répartition d'autant que on a
toujours connu que des députés radicaux
radicaux socialistes la circonscription
de Léon Blum notamment un Narbonne et là
donc c'est assez surprenant mais cela
dit le fait que tout d'un coup il est
plus une assemblée godillot et qu'on
puisse discuter je pense que en tout cas
pour vous journaliste ça fait des débats
un peu plus intéressants quoi après
c'est jusqu'à un certain moment c'est à
dire que
moi je suis obligé je trouve que le 49-3
cette année forcément un constat d'échec
mais avoir des dizaines de milliers
d'amendements c'est aussi un constat
d'échec
comment faire vivre comment ne pas
étouffer la démocratie mais Mendès
serait ravie que le que le que le que le
le Parlement que Parlement soit vivant
oui oui que ça soit pas seulement
pouvoir
très bien en tout cas le 49-3 on va le
suivre vous serez sur le pont toute la
journée sur LCP et puis ici même dès
19h30 pour pour décrypter tout ça
Richard l'oeil sur l'Europe nous emmène
à Bruxelles où les ou les ministres des
Affaires étrangères des 27 s'était réuni
réunion sur le prix de l'énergie le prix
du gaz avant un sommet de chef d'État ce
jeudi il y a deux sujets à l'agenda le
prix du gaz mais aussi des gazoducs les
tuyaux pour la cheminée
controverse importante sur les gazoiques
expliquez-nous alors effectivement il y
a deux manières d'aborder la question de
l'énergie en Europe et les risques de
grands refroidissement qu'on peut
connaître cet hiver la première c'est le
plafonnement des prix du gaz c'est une
idée sur laquelle travail la Commission
européenne à la demande des
gouvernements elle est assez simple elle
consiste à faire pression sur les pays
qui nous vendent du gaz alors je cite
l'Algérie le Qatar l'Azerbaïdjan ou
encore les États-Unis et leur dire
écoutez on est le plus grand marché du
monde pour vous il y a un prix au dessus
duquel on ne veut pas payer le gaz
l'espoir c'est que ça va marcher la
France il croit les nous les Allemands
disent attention parce que les
fournisseurs de gaz pourraient bien être
tentés de regarder du côté d'autres
clients notamment en Asie qui seraient
prêts à payer les prix du marché mais il
y a une deuxième manière d'aborder la
question du gaz et celle des
infrastructures et c'est là où ça bug
alors le défi est très simple c'est
acheminer le gaz d'un point de départ
jusqu'à un point d'arrivée et c'est
notamment le problème de ce fameux
gazeux du mid4 c'est un projet qui
devrait traverser les Pyrénées il
devrait traverser les Pyrénées de
l'Espagne parce que l'Espagne a les
moyens de recevoir le gaz liquéfié des
États-Unis de le déliquer de l'envoyer
dans les tuyaux sauf qu'il y a les
Pyrénées et que la France dit non alors
la France veut la solidarité des prix
mais pas celle des approvisionnements
c'est exactement ça alors avec un
argument Paris dit que ce n'est pas en
investissant dans un nouveau tuyau qu'il
faudra de toute manière quelques années
pour construire à travers les Pyrénées
qu'on va résoudre la question parce que
un on va accroître la dépendance
vis-à-vis du gaz liquéfié en provenance
des États-Unis et deux on ne va pas
investir dans les renouvelables trois
points de suspension et dans le
nucléaire puisque vous savez que ça
c'est le grand projet français sauf que
les Allemands s'énervent ils viennent
d'accepter de prolonger le mandat de
leur centrales nucléaire la durée
d'existence jusqu'en avril 2023 ils ont
besoin de gaz pour leur industrie
d'autant qu'il y a une vérité non dite
c'est qu'en fait la France ne veut pas
de tuyaux qui passe sur son territoire
sans qu'elle est un verrou elle
préférait que ce soit elle qui est
déterminé au gazier et qu'elle puisse
acheminer le gaz vers l'Allemagne à
partir de la France tout ça c'est une
question de souveraineté sauf qu'à force
de dire je on ne dit pas nous la
solidarité énergétique n'est pas
seulement une affaire de prix elle est
aussi une affaire de tuyau ouais la
guerre de gaz on l'amène évidemment
vis-à-vis de Poutine mais on s'amène un
peu entre nous si je comprends bien on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge on va on va
passer avec FCF tel à la question des
villes et des territoires comme chaque
semaine alors ce soir vous nous parlez
d'un acronyme Zam ou zan c'est ça zéro
artificialisation nette c'était
l'objectif de la loi climat et
résilience votée ici même à l'Assemblée
exactement Jeanne a priori ça dit rien à
personne j'ai fait un test là dans les
couloirs bon donc mais si je vous dis
étalement
urbain lotissement pavillonnaire
zone commerciale et éolienne même ou
panneaux solaires tout de suite ça vous
parle et précisément le zan vise à
réduire le rythme d'artificialisation
des sols pour arriver en 2050 à zéro
alors de deux façons soit en arrêtant
carrément de construire des logements
des supermarchés des routes etc parking
des maisons ou en compensant par une
renaturation c'est à dire que on
transforme des espaces artificialisés on
les rend à l'état de nature bon a priori
personne c'est difficile d'être contre
cet objectif de sobriété française comme
on dit à l'heure de l'urgence climatique
il nous faut lutter contre
l'imperméabilisation des sols qui qui
aggravent les inondations encourager le
recyclage des friches et puis aussi le
maître mot qui est de densifier plutôt
que de s'étendre c'est ce qu'on appelle
refaire la ville sur la ville alors
pourquoi dans ces conditions le ministre
lui-même de la transition écologique
Christophe Béchu a appelé les préfets
pour leur dire
stop on lève le stylo qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire on applique pas la loi alors
les mers ont râlé en fait c'est pour ça
parce qu'on joint l'Association des
maires de France à saisi le Conseil
d'État pour contester les décrets
d'accliplication et son président le
maire de Cannes David Lisnard a fustigé
un texte technocratique a-t-il dit qu'il
risque de s'appliquer au détriment de la
ruralité l'argument massue parce qu'en
fait si l'objectif est louable son
application risque d'être un vrai
casse-tête à commencer par la définition
même de ce qui est artificialisé ou pas
et je vais vous proposer à de jouer un
petit jeu le jeu du zan Myriam les
jardins des maisons individuelles ou les
parcs urbains c'est naturel ou
artificiel les jardins et les maisons
individuelles les jardins des maisons
les jardins les jardins c'est naturel tu
peux jouer avec moi
naturel jardin et non les 13 millions de
jardins privés sont comptés dans les
espaces artificialisés pourtant ce sont
des vrais réserves de biodiversité alors
maintenant si je vous dis un chant
traiter au pesticides artificielle et
ben non là non pas moi j'avais flairé le
piano aussi
comme un espace non artificialisé même
si elle est bourrée de pesticides
là c'est bon on est d'accord artificiel
alors en fait ce problème de définition
cache un problème de vision parce que ce
qui est visé à travers le zan c'est
encore et toujours l'étalement urbain
qui serait responsable dit-on de la
perte d'un département tous les 7 ans ce
qui est très exagéré non la France reste
très peu urbanisée par rapport aux
autres pays européens c'est moins de 10%
de sa surface certaines études dit 5% et
le rythme de la consommation des espaces
naturels est assez faibles entre 20 et
30 000 hectares par an
le problème c'est pas que les villes
s'étendent c'est la forme que prend
cette extension c'est le mitage ce qu'on
appelle le mitage c'est-à-dire des
maisons isolées qu'il faut raccorder au
réseau d'eau de gaz etc il faut
construire des routes et qui implique
tout un mode de vie assez polluant
prendre sa voiture etc mais par contre
un maire s'il veut construire lui un
équipement en limite d'urbanisation sur
une friche agricole qui trouve pas de
repreneur a priori il y a pas de
problème alors la morale de l'histoire
quelles conclusion si on vit si on veut
éviter le sort que connaissent de
nombreuses lois qui ne sont pas
appliquées parce qu'elles sont mal
fichues il faut d'abord prendre le temps
de bien définir les choses alors
objective zan oui mais d'abord objectif
Zir 0 idées reçues
natale de Carcassonne donc voilà je me
suis dit tiens c'est plus la garde de
Perpignan que le centre du monde
maintenant ça s'est déplacé à
Carcassonne
enfin je pense que ce qui est peut-être
que c'est que 5 ou 10% ce qu'il faudrait
voir c'est la progression sur les 20 30
dernières années c'est à dire que j'ai
l'impression maintenant la ville c'est
devenu que des ronds-points et des zones
industrielles et on n'arrête pas de
construire des grandes surfaces des
grandes surfaces et des hameaux voilà
qui s'étale et s'étale à la perte quand
même au détriment des vignes en 2001 ça
a beaucoup ralenti depuis le rythme
d'artifice
parce que parfois les lois sont pas
forcément si bien faites que sur le
terrain on se rend compte que
l'application va pas de soi merci merci
les affranchis à demain Elsa dormez bien
prenez des forces très belles soirées
documentaire tout de suite et à demain
donc même mieux même heure
[Musique]